it's a letter that Syed never wanted to
reach he's rejected asylum application
he's known since last Monday that the
German office for migration and refugees
or bumf has refused to recognize him in
his family as refugees he has hardly
been able to sleep since finding out
when I got my answer from BOM I was in
my practicum working in spand oh my god
like negative and then I feel very bad
and it's heartbreak and it was not
normal for me I was not waiting for this
answer okay so it explains to me that he
worked as an interpreter for NATO in
Afghanistan for six years I can't verify
this but say it has brought documents
and photos with him to Germany he went
on patrols with us and Italian soldiers
he witnessed his colleagues being killed
in an attack on the vehicle in front of
him too many of his compatriots he is a
traitor
eventually the Taliban paid him a visit
at home this says we give you a chance
to come join with us and help us I will
let you free if you come and work with
us if you didn't come with us I the next
time if you if I catch you I will burn I
will burn your family instead site fled
Afghanistan with his family they have
been in Germany since last January we
first met Seyi to his wife and child
last summer the family came to a welcome
feast for Sayid it was important to be
in touch with Germans back then he hoped
he would be able to stay here
permanently now he says the German
authorities abundant him is not possible
to go Afghanistan my house is with tal
where should I go when you work with
question parts in Afghanistan
Afghanistan Islamic country this is the
Taliban and the religious people he says
you are not Muslim because you had that
non-muslim people also you're not Muslim
they were live never let you to live in
Afghanistan so eat and his family
refused to give up they plan to appeal
the rejection of his asylum application
Syed still hopes he will be helped the
way he once helped NATO